let's switch gears and talk travel aaa
says a third of americans plan to hit
the roads for labor day weekend a lot of
them also going to be flying and it's
not going to be easy all the problems
that we've been having at the airport
airlines
well candace charles joining us live at
harry reid international this morning
and i guess you know at least one good
thing they get to get out of this heat
if they're headed somewhere candace
good morning you two good morning folks
yeah as you can see people are starting
to slowly trickle in you can look at the
board here they're arriving from all
over really a lot of folks arriving from
denver of course la
but as folks start to get out on the
road and start to come here to get on
their flights to head out of vegas what
aaa airport and local mechanics are
telling me is get out early and be
prepared to wait while both aaa and
universal motor motor cars tell me the
15 in both directions will be packed
with weakened travelers an airport
spokesperson says they're on another
record-breaking month of passengers
coming to this airport while that shows
that more people are driving because of
the flight prices more people are flying
this year than last year
quite interesting guys
we're expecting it to be busy here um
you know we just recently put out our
passenger numbers for july second
consecutive month that we've set a new
record of people utilizing this airport
and we know we see no signs of that
slowing down right now we're getting
busier we're having a higher flux of
vehicles coming in
and most of them with air conditioning
and cooling system issues
[Music]
experts say getting out on the road
early will help to avoid traffic that
will likely start picking up in the
early afternoon we already started to
see some of that as nate showed you so
for flyers as well booking the earliest
flight out can help you to avoid delays
now again expect delays in the tsa line
right now it doesn't look like it's too
crazy or crowded that's the good news
but there are also limited parking so if
you're coming here you want to park and
fly out you may want to come a little
bit early as well to look for a spot for
yourself for now i'm candice charles 8
news now